[Music]
[Applause]
Gilbert Arena's three-time NBA All-Star
with the wizard and co-host of Gill's
Arena podcast he joins us on the program
Gil let me I want to apologize up front
because it you probably got all these
people who called you once John Morant
was found with a gun in a strip club
they're like hey let's get Gilbert Arena
song because you got caught with a gun
you know in the uh in the locker room so
uh thanks for joining us how many people
reached out to you to get your thoughts
on John Moran it was a it was a few I'm
not gonna lie but you know because uh I
have my own platform
um I usually can just give my own
opinion from there but um uh I think
you're the only one I I actually
accepted oh I appreciate that what did
you think when you heard or when you saw
what he was doing live on Instagram
um since I since I've I'm the one who's
actually you know been there done that
um
I can really understand you know the
behavior
um
it's an outcry it's an outcry it's not
it's not a thug type of thing it's a
it's more of an outcry of leave me alone
of behavior you know he's being accused
of you know the um
the store incident was you know evolving
his mother and then you have the 17 year
old kid that he pulled a gun you know so
he's getting these backlashes from the
media now he wants to show everyone that
I I'm I'm this tough guy leave me alone
it's that type of behavior it's it's
it's more of an outcry a rebellion
um what would you stand what would you
say to him
it's one of those things like
I understand I understand the hurt I
understand the pain but that comes with
the job
um it comes with the job you know we're
in a spotlight and when you're in the
spotlight you have to take the good with
the bad so
um you can't act like this this is not
the behavior that actually helps you
going forward you know the only thing
that can help you is keep your head low
and and and do your job you know right
now this party in the club having fun
you know showing weapons or no weapons
that's not part of your job but I I
don't know what he's you know revolting
against or what's he angry he's got
everything Gilbert
you yes but no
um athletes athletes life is a little
harder than it seems the only time we
have peace is when we're at the job
um everything outside of the job is
nothing we are prepared for you know
you're talking about you know 19 20 21
year old kids who have all the money in
the world but not 40. we're not
businessmen we're not we're getting the
the most money at the wrong time of our
lives
um we have everyone in the world pulling
on us for loans Money I mean it's it's
if we can play the game all day and not
have to deal with reality we would but
does he want to be somebody he's not
no no it's it's a it's just like any in
in in anything in life it's a phase
um we all go through it you know when
you're a college kid you have a phase
you know when you're a young adult you
have a phase when you're in your 30s you
have a phase when you're in your 40s you
have a face you know at for some reason
with athletes you know um that that
phase between
20 to 25 you somehow think you're this
invincible you know rap star gangster
life when that's really not it it's it's
it's I don't want to blame the music but
um the music we will listen to to get
ready for games to get ready for
competition
um is going to be of the violent nature
we have to really get ourselves right
we're not listening to like some soft
drink or you know a Madonna or some you
know Mariah Carey before the game we got
to listen to the hardcore stuff that to
really get us amped up what were you
listening to
the night you brought a gun into the
locker room I wasn't listening to
anything
I wasn't listening to anything you know
my my stance was
um
I was being challenged you know someone
said they were going to do something to
me and I said I don't think you are I
want to see it so I was I was calling a
bluff I I want to see you do this let's
let's let's see how tough you are so
will will I not do that again
I can't say I wouldn't because at that
time what was making me great was
accepting all challenges you know you
say You're Gonna you know stop me from
scoring 60 I don't think you can let me
see you do it you know so mine was a
little different because it wasn't me
being aggressive
it was more of the other person being
aggressive and I need to see you do this
because okay so you bring was it
unloaded the gun
the gun yeah they were they were
unloaded okay uh if gambling dispute
between you and uh Javaris Crittenden
back in 2009. no it was not they were no
they were gambling I was poking fun at
them losing oh yeah I see here okay yeah
it had nothing to do with me actually
losing money or him owing money it was
never about you know any of that and
then you allegedly both pointed guns at
each other no I've never I never touched
a gun never had a gun
um he never pointed a gun in that isn't
that bizarre that that's the story that
you guys pointed guns at each other in
locker room yeah no it wasn't it wasn't
that it was uh the guns were on this
chair
um the guns were in his chair and it was
basically pick one the one you said
you're gonna shoot me with I want to see
it
um it was that stance and he was saying
I don't need your guns I have my own gun
oh
um yeah but was history
I don't know
oh
no listen it was it wasn't but knowing
what has happened to him since then
I'm guessing Crittenden had a loaded gun
I can't say he did or didn't was I
scared no like did I think he was in a
shooting no like we hung out every day
all day it was we have a big brother
little brother uh relationship and it
was more of the I need to stand up for
myself because he's making me look
stupid in front of the teammates it's
it's it was more of that behavior than
wow you know really feeling threatened
by anything and then you got a 50-game
suspension
yes it ended up being fit the game but
it was it was the rest of the season 38
games okay plus the team made it to
playoffs but but for the the record
we didn't get suspended for guns in a
locker room
because guns on NBA property is only two
to three games and the story was too big
for them to say oh it's only two game
suspension so I got suspended for the um
the incident well it was the behavior
detrimental detrimental to the team so
back then mental you can use Mental to
hold kids out longer so basically what
they were trying to do to Ben Simmons
early uh in Philly when he said oh
conduct detrimental to the team he
suspended
back then you can use that indefinitely
that's why he used it against him and
said oh I'm mentally I need mental I
need to do my he used that so he can sit
out as long as he wanted to
I'm glad you cleared that up
um what do you think if you're the
commissioner what do you do to John
Marin
if I'm the commissioner then because
I've been there I know I personally know
Adam Silver technically can't do nothing
um because it's it's
already been punished by his team which
is a smart move if you're the grizzly
hurry up and suspend him
um but why don't they say it's a
suspension Gilbert because they're
saying he's taking time off
it hasn't been labeled that because he
got suspended for two games by the
Grizzlies
and now he's taking time off to
reevaluate it's like a
it's like your business right you have
you have your your employee who's a very
great employee for you you don't want
this outside Trinity you know giving you
30 games that it messes up your business
so you're trying to get in front of
self-imposed yes so
um they're probably just one because
Adam Silver can't do anything he can't
suspend him into all the evidences
presented
um now how do you present evidence that
there's no weapon you can't prove that
he used the airplane with the weapon or
you don't have any proof of any of that
so you can't really do anything unless
he admits it and that's what I did I
admitted those were my guns
um so once I said I admitted it it was
like we're gonna give you 50 games and I
said well there wasn't mine how does
that work so once they realize that you
know because you know they had to do
their investigation you know the
fingerprint and stuff and realize oh we
there's no evidence
so they were like well then for for
doing this and you know mocking the
whole situation and not taking it
serious you know we're gonna suspend you
for this one when you got introduced the
starting lineup did your teammates act
like they were shooting guns at you yeah
we were uh so you remember
um oh my God what was the I know I know
right what the hell were you thinking
you remember the movie
um
even Given Sunday yeah every time they
scored a touchdown they would do it the
whole team was doing things and that was
like the part of it we all came up with
like yo when they call our names
yeah yeah
you know we even we was going to
Cleveland the next day and we were
thinking about like throwing a bomb and
then We All Fall Down oh no no no no
yeah I know I know I know he's uh
Gilbert Arena's three-time NBA All-Star
and uh he has a podcast three days a
week that's live Tuesday through
Thursday at 11 30 a.m Pacific 2 30 p.m
eastern time part of Underdog content
network available I heart app everywhere
podcast I heard
did you did LeBron reach out to you to
work uh with his son with bronnie yes
okay
when they decided to move to LA he knew
I was training kids
um so
um actually he started he started with
uh dribble too much his name is Johnny
uh handle life dribble too much you know
most of the you know all the kids you
know know him
um and then he said hey you know
bronny's working out at Heritage High
School can you go you know can you go
put your eyes on him you know you know
it was coming from a concerned father
because of the name he wanted to make
sure that you know his son was put
around you know talent to make sure no
one's picking at him so I was like okay
um I went you know I'm watching him
train I'm watching him work out and then
you know I hit LeBron and say um there's
nothing you have to worry about
um you you might be a little taller than
he is
um stronger
your speed is probably the same
um is he a better shooter is he a better
shooter than his dad yeah I said he I
said he's a better shooter
um
he he's got I mean he has the same reads
um better dribbler
um so I said you guys are even he you're
just probably a little bit taller he
probably might be a little bit more
athletic at this age than you were
um but at this point he just need reps
um your genetics is flowing through him
all he does is he just needs reps at
this point um you think he said top 10
pick
his ability
um
he he reminds me of a more F athletic
um Drew holiday
um very smart yeah he's a very smart kid
um
his downfall is that up it's it's a it's
a um it's a it's a positive for a coach
and a team he's very unselfish
um he's a very unselfish he's not the
type that would try to go out there and
score 40. he knows what he can do and
he's going to always play to his ability
and the team's ability
um
that's the downfall to me because
his ability
is he can he can go out there and
dominate a game because of what's
flowing through his body like when he
gets mad you can't stop that kid like
the high school can't stop him when he
gets mad okay but you think he can do
that in the NBA
yes you think you can be a dominating
force in the NBA he will be a
at his height
1977 type of player
um that was that he's Drew High he's
gonna be a lockdown of a Lockdown
Defender
um he'll make big plays when he needs to
um he's going to be like the the the
perfect you know uh a second option okay
now
if he decides like if he gets put on a
bad team and they say you are going to
be the number one option
he has that ability well but he's still
going to be the guy that
will like his father if I have to score
30 I'm going to score 30 but you know if
I see a play for this shooter in the
corner at the end of the game I'm I will
make that pass I will make that pass I'm
not going to force up a shot so he's
more unselfish than LeBron is too what
do you remember about the night you
scored 60 on Kobe in the Lakers because
I think Kobe had what 45 that night yeah
yes what do you remember about putting
60 on the Lakers
to be honest it
it's it's not it's not a top it's not my
top three performances it nothing was
standing out that I was on fire it
wasn't like a Clay Thompson where he's
you know he's on
um you know I had 20 something free
throws
um missed a shot to go to overtime
um I was you know very big in overtime
um
you know I was surprised that I had 60.
you know so it wasn't a a game that you
know I I'm like oh that's you know is
Kobe saying anything to you no
um before the game it's always you know
I'm guarding Gilbert I'm gonna shut him
down it's always the mind game it's
always the mind game I'm gonna shut him
down you guard him
um to try to make you really think about
what it is so you know whenever he did
that I always went into ISO basketball
just to let him know see that's the
competitive part he says I'm gonna shut
him down letting everybody know don't
worry about him he's neutralized so it's
my job to let my teammates know hey uh
don't hey first plate Let It Go
one-on-one we're gonna play one-on-one
right now right so they know all right
deal is not backing down from this
challenge we're gonna all let's go and
you know that's you know that's what
sports is about but you know my
performance is like
um that I really say
it's the 54 against uh Phoenix they were
the number one team uh on a 16-game
winning streak I told the world months
before that I'm gonna go score 50
against Dan Tony and the Suns for what
they did to me in USA Basketball so I
remember dance yeah I remember Dan Tony
saying damn you hold a grudge man I'm
Never Gonna Let You I don't want you
holding a grudge against me
yeah so so I'm in layup line and Dan
Tony said because they're the number one
team they're on fire he said um
you're gonna jokingly he said you're
gonna need more than 50 to beat us
and then I said okay I'll have more than
50 then
and end up having 54 when we won you
know who guarded you apparently nobody
no it started off with Steve Nash but
usually with Steve Nash because he was
so great at offense
I attacked him as soon as the game
started I'm trying to like get a foul on
them you know just so usually once I do
that I want
um it'll usually be
was it Raja Bell did he deal no 80 years
ago Matrix so Sean Marion will start
first okay because they're trying to if
I'm hitting shots that put a longer body
on me so it'll be the Matrix if I'm
neutralizing him then he'll go with Raja
Bell
um so they can try to use the toughness
but um usually when I'm hitting shots
they use the longer defender on this I
want to have you next time on I want to
just talk basketball with you because
I've always appreciated your your
basketball IQ of knowing the game and uh
telling stories the podcast is Gill's
Arena podcast I highly recommend it
because this is what you're going to get
from Gilbert uh Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday 11 30 a.m Pacific it's on
Underdog content network available on
the iHeart app and everywhere podcasts I
heard Gilbert great to talk to you again
and uh I meant when I said I'd love to
have you on talk some basketball here as
we get closer to the playoffs if that's
okay okay thank you thank you hey don't
beat him up too much I know we have to
do our job but you know he's still you
know still a kid so you know but I'm not
condemning I I just want to make sure he
understands I hope those around him
understand and maybe this is a footnote
in five years from now Gilbert and
that's the problem the people around him
don't understand yeah because they're
learning as he is and he's trying to
learn
um and the the funny part is if they're
at a strip club it would be his
teammates that's around him not his
friends so that's another question but
they're all young
um it will be a footnote
um
I think the reality of I almost lost
everything I could possibly lose
everything it kicked in for him to
change his behavior hopefully great to
talk to you thank you Gilbert thank you
Gilbert looks like he still put up 20.